rien tu es condamné à payer une pension
alimentaire qui n'a jamais payé
d'ailleurs les pension alimentaire non
versée
un vrai calvaire pour de nombreuses
mères célibataires depuis 50 ans il
obtient de la zone rouge
pourquoi nous dans les années soixante
dix le nombre des divorces explose
passant de 34 1877 en 1965 à 55 1612 en
1975 64% des pensions sont difficilement
ou pas du tout perçu une situation
dramatique pour de nombreuses femmes
très souvent au foyer et pour leurs
enfants pour limiter des démarches
longues coûteuses
le parlement vote alors en janvier 1973
une loi qui s'attaque aux maris
réfractaires la loi de paiement direct
sur les revenus quand une pension n'aura
pas été versé
il suffira d'aller trouver un huissier
qui s'occupera lui même de la saisie du
salaire les services de l'état devront
lui transmettre tous les renseignements
qu'ils possèdent
malgré cette réforme novatrice de
nombreuses tensions ne sont toujours pas
payés françois giroux secrétaire d'état
à la condition féminine créée en 1975 un
service de recouvrement des pensions un
pays
gare aux mauvais payeurs ce sera
désormais le percepteur qui se chargera
de recouvrer la pension alimentaire non
payés il faut que ceux qui ne paient pas
comprennent qu'ils auront intérêt à
payer parce qu'ils seront retrouvés et
parce qu'ils seront largement pénalisés
un voeu pieux dans les années 1980 les
divorces continue de progresser
deux tiers des femmes ne touchent
toujours pas régulièrement de pension
alimentaire
l'état met alors en place un fonds d'
avance de pension versée par les caisses
d'allocations familiales
ces dernières s'occupe ensuite de
récupérer l'argent auprès des maris
créanciers cette allocation de soutien
familial sera versé à titre d' avance
sur la créance alimentaire qui est dû et
sera de ce fait recouvrables
récupérables auprès du parents
défaillants par la caisse d'allocations
familiales
ces mesures sont toujours en application
aujourd'hui c'est
le taux d'impayés des pensions a baissé
mais il aussi est toujours entre 30 et
40 % en 2016 2017
un nouveau palier est franchi avec
l'ouverture de l' agence de recouvrement
des impayés des pensions alimentaires
géré par la caf
il ya la possibilité pour nous de voir
sur ses différents comptes bancaire s'il
ya le disponibles nous allons pouvoir
voir en fonction de sa situation
professionnelle qu'elles sont aussi ces
ressources grâce à cette agence le taux
de recouvrement aussi entre 63 et 64 %
petit à petit c'est donc une nouvelle
philosophie qui se met en place
désormais les familles monoparentales ne
dépendront plus du versement aléatoire
de la pension elle sera versée par
l'état qui lui se chargera de percevoir
les sommes dues
[Musique]